from the innocent young gorillas
dangerous liaison
-
uma Thurman
good evening it is my privilege to
present the award for best achievement
in makeup the nominees are for Edward
Rick Baker fee Neil and Yolanda to sing
turn smiling Martin Landau into the
agent scowling star of another
generation Bela Lugosi
for Forrest Gump Daniel C Street pick
Halle d'amour and Judith a quarry took
principal Sally Field and Tom Hanks over
a period of several decades who peace
war and Savannah Georgia for Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein Daniel Parker
Paul England and Harold hemming went
into their workshop to design fabricate
and then apply a diabolical creature who
was brought to monstrous life
the award goes to Rick Baker
well first of all we'd like to thank the
Academy for having this category Tim
Burton Denise denovi and touchstone
pictures for making the film Scott and
Larry for their screenplay all of the
actors but especially Martin for his
cooperation and brilliant performance
I'd like to thank these talented women
up here with me as well as all the other
makeup and hair people that contributed
to Ed Wood and lastly I'd like to thank
the late great makeup artist Jack Pierce
Jack's makeups were the first to inspire
me to get into this business where they
not only pay and feed you but honor you
for doing something that you truly love
thank you very much
give me a hand here
hey I have something here I want to show
you let me just put this down by the way
I have the feeling I'm not the only one
here tonight carrying his rug
can you you want to help just are you
gonna love this do you mind you would
just come up here and give us an yeah do
you mind just just come on up here come
on this would be great
thanks Don thanks Ricky
Tom Hanks just roll roll it up roll that
up if you can't just thank you very much
would it kill you to have worn a tie
all right no you can stay up here I want
you sister alright ladies gentlemen do
me a favor don't applaud now until I ask
you to applaud and I don't think you'll
have trouble with that all right
I don't introduce you to somebody all
right come right out the hole hold your
applause come on wait a minute come on
here we go oh my god this is this is
Sadie the dog that spins when you
applaud here we go just
what do you think of that okay all right
okay
okay flip her up okay here you how about
that yes sir we got us a self-winding
dog ladies gentlemen thank you very much
nice job Stacy towns ladies gentlemen oh
I'll take care of it that was just as
good as winning something wasn't it
but nice every little Tom Hanks let it
go
I'm sorry